Något som ingen trodde på, det var om man ska prata strategi här, om man ska bli ensam om någonting.
När det gäller strategi så är det bättre att vara ensam än att vara bättre.
Only is better than best.
Make Sweden stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi David från Icebug till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Och David, eller Icebug kanske man ska säga, är ett av få företag som...
Detta är nog första gången i poddens historia som vi kommer snacka lite grann om typ företagsvärderingar.
För jag har väldigt svårt för det normalt sett när jag pratar med företag.
Jag tycker att det finns mycket greenwashing och socialwashing och jag tycker att folk snackar mycket skit.
Jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Men ni är faktiskt ett företag som på riktigt backar upp det lite grann.
Det tycker jag ska bli kul att prata om.
Är du en god människa David?
Haha, jag tror det först när det gäller företagsvärderingar.
Att det här var en sån tröjansk häst så vi skulle prata om vad är värdet på bolaget och du har frukt köpa här nu.
Om jag är en god människa, jag tror inte jag riktigt vill göra den bedömningen, men jag är väldigt intresserad och har varit ganska länge intresserad av den frågan hur lever man ett gott liv?
Ja, det är väl inte onda människor som börjar fundera på det eller?
Nej, det kanske inte är det.
Jag har inte heller tänkt på det på det sättet, men det sönderfaller i två delar sådär.
Dels är det ju okej hur, ja men hur lever jag ett liv som jag uppskattar och vill ha?
Och hur gör jag det också på ett sätt som mer bidrar till världen och till andra människors väl än tvärtom?
Har du alltid gått runt i sådana tankar eller när slog den här switchen över?
Jag tror alltid att tanken om att man vill bidra med mer positivt än man drar ifrån som negativt.
Och sen så, nu första jag studerade efter gymnasiet var filosofi.
Och där blev ju de frågorna, eller filosofi hade ju två delar då, en var ju såhär, teoretisk filosofi, såhär, finns världen?
Och det är ju kul att fråga sig ett tag, tyckte jag.
Och sen så blev jag ju såhär, ja men jag tror att världen finns, så jag utgör från det.
Och då blir den där lite mer praktiska sidan av filosofin då, hur filosofi som någonting som är levd, ja men hur lever jag då för det här.
Så det har jag funnits med länge, sen så tog det ju den här vägen till att bli entreprenör eller bygga företag.
Jag var ju egentligen aldrig så jätteintresserad av att driva företag, absolut inget intresse av att bli någon sorts miljöaktivist.
Så när jag började jobba med att driva företag, då var det ganska länge såhär, det blev som en sak i sig själv, att man liksom lekte lite med, men hur gör man det här och hur får man det här att funka?
Och sen blev vi ju liksom, när jag mognade och blev lite öksnare i den här rollen, och totalt sett så kom jag väl tillbaks till den där frågan, men starkare.
Och då funderade jag på, men hur kan jag också verkligen sätta ihop det här, så att mitt liv och jag sitter ihop, så att jag inte har de här funderingarna när jag är privata David, då ska jag till jobbet åtta timmar per dag och gör något annat, där man spelar efter andra spelregler.
Det blir lite skizofrent och det blir liksom ett inre skav, och det där inre skavet ville jag undvika.
Var det så innan du gick runt med en stickad kofta utanför företagsstörren, och sen när du gick in på bolaget så tog du av den, du drog bak vattenkammningen och helt plötsligt var det hela andel som gällde.
Nej, jag har nog aldrig känt något behov av att klä mig på ett visst sätt på jobbet.
Men just den där vilka spelregler man spelar efter, vad är det man har för syfte?
Går jag in på jobbet, tar jag som syfte att maxa vinst?
Eller tar jag också andra ansvar?
Och ganska länge så var det ju så när vi startade så skobranschen är ju jättesvårt på det sättet att ta till väldigt höga minumikvantiteter.
Och det är ganska få skoföretag som finns, speciellt som gör den här typen av mer tekniska sportskor.
Och det beror ju på den här saken.
Det är mycket lättare att göra kläder till exempel, där kan man göra småserier.
Och väldigt länge så var vi för små för att kunna ställa några andra krav på våra fabriker än att göra det som är standardlösningen.
Och standardlösningen är aldrig den lösningen som tar sitt största resursansvar.
Så där var det en ganska lång tid från att vi hade bestämt eller vi hade bestämt att vi ville ta ett stort ansvar för resursanmänning.
Eftersom vi är i den här earth overshoot modellen där vi förbrukar mer resurser än planeten kan återskapa.
Till att vi faktiskt kunde börja jobba med alternativ där man har mindre negativ miljö påverkan.
Så där fanns en skavperiod som var ganska tydlig under 5-7 år.
Jag kanske ska säga det så att folk vet om också.
Du äter ju David och du äger ett bolag som heter Icebug och ni tillverkar skor och säljer skor som är ska vi säga dubbade skor, eller skor med grepp, eller skor med fäste.
Hur säger ni?
Fästskor?
Nej, det ska jag vara.
Fästskor var ny faktiskt.
Nej, vi har ju byggt varumärket kring grepp.
Så där, vårt mål är ju att vi ska, det har vi blivit på engelska då eftersom empower är mycket bättre på engelska än bemündiga på svenska.
Ni kan inte, fan ni borde dra upp för en reklam kan fan, så det är nog det sämsta ordet.
Fler människor kan ta sig ut mer och då har ju skor med grepp varit vår lösning på det problemet och då har jag ju varit, från början så var det dubbade skor, men sådana här dynamiska dubbar som kan röra sig in och ut i surland som för vinterbruk.
För då har jag ju att man kan springa på allt ifrån torr asfalt till ren is.
Och sen så har vi kompletterat med greppgummi och designer för grepp även för vår sommar-höst.
Så vi har ju byggt, och det är ju fortfarande vårt första varumärkslöfte, det är ju enastående grepp.
Så Eismar är ju byggt på grepp.
Ni har läst på här lite om er så det i sig verkar ha varit ett problem i början, men någon sorts konflikt i början.
Att folk inte trodde att greppskor skulle vara en sak.
Eller du fick typ kritik för det?
Ja kritik är väl lite, men det var ju väldigt få i branschen som trodde på affärsideen.
Det fanns för någon så här tidig, det var ju när vi fortfarande sökte kapital och sådär och ville ha investeringar.
Det var någon som bedömde att världsmarknaden för det här kanske är 1500 par.
Det visade sig vara lite mer.
Så det fanns ju en väldigt tydlig bild i början.
Att ja men det där är bråddare, det där är bara för pensionärer.
Det som gjorde att vi fortfarande kunde tro ganska starkt på det var det att vi testade själva om man fick den här wow-upplevelsen av att plötsligt ha grepp där man inte förväntar sig det.
Och vi väldigt tidigt när vi lyckades komma ut på marknaden fick den här typen av respons från användare.
Så här, det här förändrar mitt liv.
Vi har en ganska bred kundpalett, så vi kan säga att det är hela vägen från värdkilit till rollator.
Så det är liksom så här bergslöpar, orienterare och sådär.
Och sen så är det de som faktiskt inte vågar gå ut på vintern utan våra produkter.
Så de tar sig liksom till brevlådan och till ICA och kan handla och sådär.
Och jag tycker att den bredden är väldigt fin och känner att det liksom betyder någonting för ganska många olika människor.
Men från början var det ju verkligen något som ingen trodde på.
Om man ska prata strategi här så, om man ska bli ensam om någonting.
Och när det gäller strategi så är det bättre att vara ensam än att vara bättre.
Only is better the best.
Vad som är bra då är att spela med det här weird or normal.
Och vi tog något som var weird, skor med dubbar, och gjorde det till någonting normalt via att det först var en nisch och sen blev det en kategori.
Och nu är det ju så i Sverige och Finland åtminstone att från Stockholm och norrut så är dubbade skor det man har på vintern när det är halt.
Och kunder går in i butiker och frågar efter icebag.
Och då menar de dubbade skor.
Så vi är i princip synonym med kategorin och är fortfarande väldigt starkt marknadsledande i den här dubbade skor.
Så det är en väldigt, vi gjorde ju den här resan, tog någonting weird och gjorde det i norma.
Och sen så skapade en egen kategori, som är en ganska stor kategori i sko-
och sportbranschen på vintern i Scandinavien.
Hur stort kan man dra?
Det kan ni göra liksom toffler för sjukhusen.
Alltså du vet, äldre, att det blir standard.
Istället för att ha någon sorts sock i plast så får man en...
Ja, alltså om man ska vända på det då så är det vi har gjort för vår sommar är att för att ta något som är ganska normalt och skruva till lite.
Så där är vi mest framgångsrika med det som är lätta, bekväma, ganska clean designade lifestyle-skor för att ha hela tiden.
Och så har vi vårt greppgummi på dem.
Det är ju inte såhär uppenbar, det gör det lite weird så att vi är unika.
Någonting annat än sketcher som inte har det.
Och det har ju varit väldigt framgångsrikt för det är en del i vården som använder våra produkter även om vi inte satsar på det.
Ja men det har ju också blivit väldigt stort för de som är ut på klippor och sådär, där det är där man faktiskt då behöver en bättre grepp.
Så de som lever båtliv på sommaren.
Om man tittar på hur man växer med saker, så oftast blir det ju en S-kurva.
Och det beror ju på att man har en del förstärkande faktorer, eller förstärkande lopar, som gör att man växer.
Har man inga sådana så kommer man inte växa alls.
Och sen så när man blir träckligt stor så blir de här balanserande loparna, då blir de stärkare och stärkare så att man planar ut det.
Svaret på frågan är att vi vet inte riktigt.
Men kan vi inte fastna i, jag gillar den modellen, vad är era förstärkande lopar och vad är era ihållande lopar och liknande?
Vad är det som ligger och tickar?
Ja men vi har efter en otroligt stark loop, den som jag pratade om från början, att det här wow-faktorn är väldigt stark.
Och den leder till att vi har väldigt hög rekommendationsgrad.
När vi mäter sådana här Net Promoter Score, alltså ju sannolikt det egentligen är att någon ska berätta för någon att våra grejer är bra rekommenderade, så ligger vi ju nästan allt i en bit över 80.
Och här är allt över 0 ju bra egentligen, allt över 50 ju väldigt bra.
Så vi ligger ju superstarkt där.
Så det är där att man faktiskt berättar, speciellt för sådana man bryr sig om och inte vill ska halka på vintern och berättar men de här skorna är fantastiska.
Det där är ju en stark förstärkande loop som också blir självförstärkande eftersom vi inte behöver jobba någonting med den egentligen.
När grejerna kommer ut så gör de sitt eget jobb.
Sen så blir det en annan förstärkande loop när vi blir tillräckligt stora för att göra bred reklam.
Vi har ju gjort såhär, sponsrat vädret och gjort tv-reklam relativt länge nu.
Det blir ju också en förstärkande loop där.
Vem var det som kom på att ni skulle sponsra vädret?
Det är ju faktiskt skitbra.
Jag minns faktiskt inte.
Antagligen jag när jag står här.
Nej jag vet faktiskt inte.
Det är ju många sådana saker som växer fram där det blir lite otydligt vens idé det är.
Vi gjorde ju först någon vanlig reklamfilm och sen så blev Värde-spons var från 4-5 år sedan vi har jobbat med det.
Det blir en förstärkande faktor och även sådär när det blir den här, man går från nisch till kategori, då blir det ju det här om en butiker gör bra business med det.
Då berättar ju också butiker för andra butiker där de känner folk inom kedjor och strädare och olika.
Så det blir ju också en förstärkande faktor.
Sen så kan man ju se då, nu pratar jag ganska mycket fortfarande om våra dubbade skor, sen så kan man ju se vad som blir balanserande faktorer här.
När vi blir riktigt stora, vilket vi har blivit, vi har ju varit till exempel den största, på Intersport Finland, vilket är hälften av den finska sportmarknaden, där har vi varit det bäst säljande och volym-mässigt största skovarumärket under vinteralvåret.
Och det är klart att över tid så passerar ju inte sådant obemärkt.
Så då kommer det ju en massa andra aktörer som också gör då billigare produkter med dubbar och andra starka varumärkningar i löpning som också gör.
Så då blir konkurrens en begränsande faktor.
Och också att alla inte är redo att investera 1500-2000 kronor i ett par skor med dubbar för att vara aktivt på vintern.
Fan det här kommer bli svårt att hålla den röda tråden i det här avsnittet känner jag.
Men jag ska försöka beta av ni som lyssnar får bara tåla att vi gör några hopp ibland för att jag känner att det här måste vi få med.
Vi ska gå tillbaks lite grann.
Jag tycker fan, vi får göra såhär.
Vi går tillbaks lite grann.
Men ni har en ganska rolig startstory.
Eller jag gillar genuina grundarstories.
Kan inte du ge oss lite hur det drog igång och vilka som startade bolaget?
Det var ju jag och min mamma som startade.
Hon var en länge framgångsrik designer inom sportswear-segmentet.
Jag vet inte om du kommer ihåg, du kanske är för ung för det, men Hang 10 till exempel.
Det var jättestort som skikleds och som sommarsurfmärke, som mode, inte så många surfar i Sverige på 80-talet.
Men det hade hon gjort och sen var hon ju i skobranschen som designer.
Så hon hade alltid varit bra på att göra kommersiell design, men kanske inte så business smart.
Hon hade gjort andra rika men inte sig själv.
Och sen så var det hennes bästa leverantör från Taiwan.
De hade jobbat exklusivt med ett skandinaviskt bolag länge.
Men de var inte så nöjda med utvecklingen där, så de frågade henne om de ville bli våra representanter och bearbeta den skandinaviska marknaden.
Och så var hon sugen på det, för hon kom väldigt bra överens med dem och så pratade hon om det.
I samband med det så hade jag precis blivit utlasad som journalist på GT.
Jag sa att jag skulle flytta till Stockholm och göra samma grej på Aftonblad till Expressen.
Jag var inte så sugen när jag hade jobb i Bidran från GP och jag gjorde samma sak, men det var tråkigare än kvällstidning då.
Så då tänkte jag att jag inte skulle göra det här några år då.
Och så kan jag tjäna så mycket pengar så att jag faktiskt kan sluta jobba.
Och så blir jag romanförfattare istället, men behöver inte bryna om det.
Drömmarna, drömmarna.
Jag jobbar hårt några år med det här.
Jag gillar ungt och naivt i låten.
Så jag startade ett företag som hette MVP, som Million Dollar Project.
Fan vad underbart, fan vad glad jag blir.
Det är fan vitt företag där.
På sätt med det, det gick ganska snabbt.
Det gick jättebra för oss i början med det där att vi gjorde design, produktion åt andra skandinaviska varumärken och åt de stora kedjorna.
Men sen förändrades det där.
Kinesiska fabriker blev bättre på att gå direkt.
Och våra kunder blev mindre och mindre intresserade av design och kvalitet.
Utan de ville ha kopier som man inte kunde ha blivit ständ för.
Så billigt som möjligt.
Det finns aldrig något botten i pris heller.
Så vi kände att även om det var en fungerande affärsmodell så var det verkligen något som var i en hal utförsbacke.
Så då tänkte vi att om vi ska kunna göra någonting vi känner att vi kan stå för produkterna då behöver vi starta ett eget varumärke.
Och då var det det vi var duktiga på var vinterprodukter.
Men då var det varma, välfordrade vattentäta produkter som bröt mot det som var standard ändå, som var skot i kängor.
Och så hittade vi våra taiwaner i samband med att vi höll på att starta röset, hitta våra taiwaneriska partner.
En liten artikel i Runners World USA, där det var någon kanadensisk tretlighet som också ägde en gummifabrik som hade tagit fram den här sullteknologin, då var det en väldigt basic löpsko som var testad.
Och då tänkte vi att det där är ju faktiskt inte bara för löpning, utan det kan ju lösa det stora problemet med skor på vintern överhuvudtaget, att man halkar.
Det finns ju även ganska gott om produkter som håller fötterna varm och torra.
Så då bestämde vi oss för att starta det som blev IceBug.
Och det där är ju liksom lite, det är som jag sa för ett skoföretag är svårt.
Och just det där man måste ändå ta på något sätt annan plats på hyllan från de giganterna som finns.
Så det var ju lite som att först starta ett eget varumärke, som man först tillbringade ett antal år med att gräva ett riktigt djupt hål.
Och sen så fick man liksom lägga ett antal år på att fylla det där hålet.
Och sen började det liksom synas någonting över mark, typ.
För det är också så som konsumentvarumärke, så måste man ha alla funktioner på plats.
Du måste leverera i tid, du måste ha någon typ av marknadsföring, du måste ha bra produkter, så där.
Det var ju också innan det fanns egentligen någon fungerande internetförsäljning.
Vad var de första produkterna ni tog in?
Det var fortfarande löpaskor eller?
Vi gjorde, kollektionen från början var en mix, det var löpaskor och så var det vinterkänger kan man säga.
Lite olika typer av värde.
Var det inte ganska klaxigt att ändå gå på en, inte bara en nisch av skor i ett första, men som du säger, det är höga, minimum, order-volymer.
Ni ska ta in en ny grej på marknaden, här är en egen nisch och så bara, vi ska inte bara stå på den här platsen i butiken, vi behöver komma in på tre platser i butiken.
Det är en jävla massa kapital och lite krångligt att sälja in.
Lite krångdristigt kanske.
Ja och dessutom så var det inte så där, det var inte aktuellt för oss att börja bara i Sverige, utan vi började ju, vi lanserade ju på Ispo som var världens, som var världens största sportpopuläser.
Och började väl på iallafall tio marknader samtidigt.
Så Kanada, Tyskland, Österkirch, Schweiz, Skandinavien, Norra Österkirchen och Slaken också.
Ja, så det var stora ambitioner på att det skulle gå väldigt snabbt.
Hur fort gick det där i början?
Du sa att ni grävde ett hål och sen fyllde hålen.
Men hur snabbt?
Tog företaget fart?
Det gick inte alls snabbt.
Varje sommar var det för man höjde den här.
Vi hade hela tiden den tidigare affären som kunde finansiera det här.
Kunde finansiera driften kan man säga, så vi kunde jobba med det.
Ni körde simultant liksom?
Ja, precis.
Det tog 8-9 år innan Iceberg fungerade på riktigt.
Hur många gånger satt ni i köket och bara, fan det här, fan har vi gjort nu?
Varje sommar var det något indiskt reptrick när man skulle betala fabrikerna och få hem varen och sedan leverera ut dem och få betalt 5-6, eller 2-3 månader senare.
Det var framförallt en sommar när vår tysk distributör gick i konkurs.
Det var ganska tufft faktiskt.
Då fick jag väl prata med min dåvarande sambo som jag hade små barn med.
Eller en liten nyförelse.
Det här kanske skitser liksom.
I värsta fall så får vi flytta till dina föräldrars garage.
Det är okej, då gör vi det i så fall.
Men ni slapp?
Ja, vi slapp.
På något sätt lyckades vi hela tiden.
Vi lyckades ju också, vi försökte vid några tillfällen när det var jobbigt sådär att ta in kapital.
Det misslyckades vi också med.
Vi är väldigt glada för nu.
Har ni aldrig tagit in kapital?
Nej.
Det är kaxigt.
Nya modeller, bindat kapital, många marknader.
Ni ska bygga varumärken i en sån som man behöver på något sätt känna till er.
Det är ganska kapitaltät.
Ja, precis.
När vi ville så var det ingen som ville.
Nu vill inte vi.
Det är textur till tango.
Jag förstår.
Sen vill jag också fastna till lite grann på det här jag snackade om här i början.
Att ni verkar vara ett gott företag så att säga.
Ni gör ju en del skumma grejer, eller skumma är det väl inte men det är ju skumt i någon sorts kontext av att andra inte gör så.
Ni har någon sorts, eller ni hade i alla fall förra året vet jag, för jag hajar till på den här reklamen att försäljningen på, om det är Black Friday eller någonting, skänkte ni till välgörenhet?
Ja, precis.
Ja men det vi har gjort, jag tror det blir fjärde året vi gör just den specifika saken.
Så vi kallar det Green Friday och då sänker vi inte några priser men vi ger allt till olika typer.
Först var det ju bara det här naturarvet som köper hotad gammelskog.
Det har vi gjort lite olika på lite olika marknader men det är ju organisationen som försöker skydda skidsvärt skog.
Så sloganen, jag vet inte om vi ska köra den i år igen, men det är köp en skog, få en skog.
Ah nice.
Men det fungerar, nej fan jag vet inte vad jag tänkte på engelska, run, nej, by issue.
Run forest run.
Ja men någonting med forest du blir, det var bara så jag kopplade.
Jag bara minns den här kampanjen för då, jag hade givetvis ingen kontakt med dig då, men jag såg den här Icebug-kampanjen och jag reagerade på det för jag vet att jag gick in och kollade er bokslut och sen tror jag att ni skrev att ni hade sålt rekord eller någonting och jag började räkna på undrar hur mycket det var de gav i väg här och vad det blir i procent av omsättningen.
Allting över typ 0,2 procent av ens omsättning är ju sjukt mycket pengar om man ska räkna in det.
Så det blir ganska mycket pengar.
Ja men precis, vi är ju 1 procent for the planet sedan fem år nu eller något.
Så det betyder ju att vi har signat undrat minst 1 procent av vår omsättning donerar vi till framförallt miljörörelser som stöttar dem.
Och det är ju mycket pengar.
Så vi omsätter ju, ja men vi hade ju något superår som var 300 miljoner då.
Men det var ju när det var covid och så.
Det var 364 miljoner, låt oss inte vara oblygsamma här.
Ja okej det var så, ja okej.
Men nu är vi ju nere någonstans och vi är liksom strax under.
Jag tror vi kanske kommer upp till 300 miljoner igen här nu.
Bara?
Nej, i skobranschen är det ju ganska litet då.
Ett ganska stort litet företag eller ett litet medelstort företag kan man väl säga så där.
Men det blir ändå, det blir ju typ tre miljoner per år.
Och det är ju klart att eftersom jag är ägare så hade ju det där också kunnat vara pengar man hade haft som i utdelningen och så där.
Det här går ju också tillbaks i vad tänker man är rätt saker att göra och vi tänker att vi behöver vara med och bidra till.
Och det är det vi har bestämt att vi vill använda företag till.
Inte maximera vinst utan att maximera positiv påverkan mot sådär ett samhälle där människor kan blomstra på en planet som är i balans.
Och då behöver man ju på något sätt leverera på det och det gör vi ju framför allt och där går vi väl mer och mer åt att framförallt så gör vi det genom att vi vill ha en tydlig hypotes att när vi når våra affärsmål och det går bra för oss så går det faktiskt också bättre för världen.
Men sen så har vi också den här delen där vi tänker att av det värdet vi skapar, vi tittar ju på värdeskapande och då säger vi ja men vinst är en del av värdeskapande, det vi betalar i löner är en annan del av värdeskapande.
Så får man titta på det finansiella värdeskapandet som är vinst, får man titta på vad är en bra fördelning av det och det blir också om man tittar på det som värdefördelning eller värdedistribution, då blir det också mycket mindre jobbigt att betala skatt.
Då kan vi säga att det här är ju faktiskt den värdedistribution vi gör till samhället.
Men vi har också bestämt att den här procenten av omsättningen som ju då händer även om vi inte är lönsamma, så det ställer ju höga krav på att vi är lönsamma.
Den tänker vi då ska vara ungefär 10% av vinsten om vi har 10% vinstmagno.
Det är också vad vi sätter att ägarna ska ha som utdelning och vi har en liknande som är vinstdelning med personalen.
Så det blir ungefär lika stora delar som går till planeten, till personalen och till ägarna.
Även ägarnas och personalens vinstdelning är den omsättningsdriven eller får ni kära vinst?
Naturen får alltid sitt men ni andra får vänta på vinsten.
Ja precis så är det.
Den går på vinst på vinst med en stopp och att vi också behöver ha ett positivt kassaflöde.
One percent for the planet är ju en extern...
Det är ett avtal vi ska vara på och det gör ju också...
Så man kan ju se det på det här sättet, okej.
Det är en procent, det gör ju också att vi kan använda deras logo och när kan man liksom ge en en procent till rabatt och samtidigt få någon typ av tydligare sådär, att folk tycker att det är någonting som är ett värde när man står vid ett köpbeslut mellan två olika produkter till exempel.
Så jag tror att vi också får ut värde av det, samtidigt så kan man ju inte göra det för att man ska få ett varumärkets värde av det.
För då tror jag att man kommer att tappa i längden.
Sen har ni gjort lite sådana här sidogrejer på detta.
Ni har lagt något tak på hur mycket era skor får släppa ut och liknande.
Jag tycker alltid att sådana här initiativ är...
För du pratade förut om sluttande, du sa att priserna kan alltid bli lägre.
Och jag anser att man kan alltid bli snällare.
Jag tycker sånt alltid är lite läskigt.
Där sätter vi gränsen, hur snällare ska vi bli?
Ja men exakt.
Ja men en procent är ju väldigt logiskt.
Det kan man förstå.
Ja men en procent av omsättningen ska gå till det här.
Men att sätta ett värde för så här mycket får skorna bidra med i koldioxidutsläpp.
Var det ni hade det här?
Det där är ju ganska, vi har ju satt så här vi är med i något som heter Exponential Roadmap Initiative och det är ju i det här större ramverket av Raise to Zero.
Då finns ju Carbon Law att förhålla sig till för liksom hela samhället och alla företag.
Och då behöver vi halvera till 2030 från 2020 årsnivå.
Och sen så behöver vi halvera igen till 2040.
Ja det är så man räknar, okej.
Ja precis, sen halvera igen till 2050.
Och 2050 är då det här berömda Net Zero.
Och så har jag inte trott att någon har en aning om hur vi ska klara i nuläget.
Men det viktigaste är ju eftersom, ja men koldioxid i atmosfären, det är ju som att fylla på ett atmosfären.
Vi kan ju se det som ett stort badkal liksom.
Så det är ju mycket viktigare att vi klipper utsläpp de här första 50 procenten än att fundera på om vi lyckas med de sista 10 procenten.
För volymen utsläpp blir så mycket mycket större.
Och det här förvånar mig att jag vet inte om politiker i Sverige faktiskt inte förstår detta.
Eller om de bara struntar i det.
För det här att vi når inte våra mål nu, men vi kommer nog att nå 20-50 målen.
Det är ganska, om vi inte under hela den här resan minskar våra utsläpp tillräckligt mycket, så är det ganska ointressant om vi går till 0-20-50.
För då har vi redan överskrivit hela den här budgeten.
Vi har redan fyllt atmosfären med så mycket koldioxid.
När vi inte har minskat från den här 100 procentnivån.
Det är klart att de första 50 procenten är viktigare än de sista tio.
Så det är det vi har satt som var hela ramp.
Så på det sättet har vi satt oss själva i en koldioxidbudget.
För att vara med i det här övergripande tanksättet.
Det här är lite för rufft och det är där man jobbar också med att utveckla det här.
Nu börjar konceptet Climate Solution Providers komma.
Att man är en del av en lösning.
För om man tänkt sig att vi inte kan bara ha en statisk problembild av detta.
Som är såhär, vi ska leva exakt som vi gör nu.
Ha exakt samma näringsliv om tio år, tjugo år.
Så funkar det inte i marknadsekonomi.
Och sen så ska vi bara hitta sätt att halvera utsläppen av det exakt som vi gör nu.
Det är mycket mer intressant att titta på.
Okej, vilka branscher, aktiviteter, sektorer är lösningsleverantörer mot en värld där tio miljarder människor kan leva blomstrandeliv på en regenerativ planet, så att säga, globalt hållbar blomstrandeliv.
Det betyder ju då att är man en sådan lösningsaktör av en sig, det är ju helt orimligt om de som tillverkar solceller till exempel ska minska sina absoluta utsläpp för att vara någon som bidrar till att lösa klimatproblemet.
Det är väl lite samma sätt vi jobbar där och tittar på okej på vilket sätt är det vi kan vara en lösning här mot att hjälpa till och addera blomstrande livsår som är globalt hållbara.
Och då är ju nära outdoor aktiviteter en superbra grej här.
Gå i skogen med familjen på helgen istället för att åka till allum eller torp och handla grejer liksom.
Fuck those shops.
Nej va?
Nej.
Eller, så vi behöver liksom se såhär vad är det och det är ju marknadsföring så säljer man ju alltid någonting.
Vad är det som är ett eftersträvansvärt liv är det man försöker sälja ofta och så försöker man ju trycka på lite knappar så man känner sig lite tom inuti om man inte försöker ta sig ditåt.
Och så spajsar man upp det med att det ska finnas en känsla av att om jag kanske missar någonting här, om jag inte slår till nu för att jag är nedräckt, det här gäller bara till ikväll klockan 23.59 eller här är en lite gränsad upplage eller här är någon influencer jag gillar jättemycket som säger att det är bra grejer.
Där går vi emot, vi försöker verkligen designa också och det här tror jag är kanske det som du pratar om, men vi gör inte Black Friday.
Det finns en större sak där som är att vi försöker verkligen designa våra säljprocesser så att de inte triggar över konsumtion, utan att man gör ett övertänkt köpbeslut för att det är någonting man behöver och tänker att man kommer använda.
Så vi är liksom inte nöjda bara att någon köper ett par skor, och det är typ att säga att vi förbjuder det här och pratar om konsumenter.
Alla är kunder, där finns en tydlig transaktion.
Sen vill vi att kunderna ska bli användare av produkterna, inte förbrukare av produkterna, så att de verkligen använder produkterna för att ta sig ut mer.
För det är vår hypotes att de flesta av oss mår bättre av mer fysisk aktivitet.
Det finns ytterligare plusseffekter om vi gör det i naturen, att connecta till naturen, connecta till oss själva.
Och ytterligare plusseffekter om vi gör det tillsammans med andra och får en gemenskap utav det.
Hur balanserar du den här, vad ska vi kalla det då, men miljövärdnadsvurmen med att faktiskt driva bolag och pusha?
Ja, för ni är ju ett högst fungerande bolag som uppenbarligen gör väldigt mycket rätt skarpt liksom, men ni vill ju inte sitta hela lunchrummet och bara prata om vilket talbarsté som är godast hela lunchen, utan ni måste ju också prata om hur ska vi penetrera den här marknaden på bäst sätt och mörda den här konkurrenten.
Alltså, hur hittar man balansen i det där?
Och den bygger på att vi tänker att så länge vi gör produkter som människor faktiskt har använt för att ta sig ut mer, ja men där finns en anledning för oss att växa.
Så vi gör produkter som är bra på det sättet och där är vi också mest intresserade av att mäter inte bara i första skedet, vad är koldioxidavtrycket, utan vad är det per användning.
Och då kan man först gå till en så här, vad är den faktiska slitstyrkan, men sen vill man ju gå till vad är den faktiska användningen också, där är vi inte riktigt framme och kan mäta än.
Men att man har ett lågt avtryck per användning så att vi löser det här behovet, för det finns ju faktiskt ett behov för människor att ha bra skor för att kunna ta sig ut.
Så om vi löser det behovet på ett bra sätt och blir bidrar till att fler människor kommer ut, där finns vår license to grow.
Men jag tänker att det finns något här i att vi vill växa för att vi vill öka vår, det vi tycker är en positiv påverkan på världen, men vi vill inte växa i all evighet.
Vi vill växa tills vi hittar vad som är vår naturliga storlek.
Och då tänker vi att den naturliga storleken är när vi har maxat vad vi kan göra utan att börja göra saker för att trigga över konstruktion.
Nu försöker vi få folk att köpa nya grejer som de egentligen inte behöver.
När vi kommer dit, då har vi passerat gränsen för vad vi ser som vår naturliga storlek.
Så den bilden vi har odlat fram här, vi är mycket mer intresserade, vi har funnits i 25 år nu.
Jag tänkte på det redan när vi blev 20 år, mitt perspektiv förändras, jag är mer intresserad av vad är nästa 20 år än vad är nästa 20 månader.
Vi vill ju finnas kvar länge.
Då är bilden att vi vill bli som en riktigt gammal ek.
Träd slutar inte växa när de är tre meter, men de växer inte eller till att bli tre kilometer höga.
De växer till att de har det som är deras rätta potential och storlek också givet vad de är för miljö.
Sen så växlar de från expansion till att frodas eller blomstra.
Då kan de fortfarande växa rotsystem så att de står starkare och verkligen leva och vara hälsosamma i ekars fall i flera hundra år.
Jag köper att det här är en väldigt fin, jag gillar den metaforen, den är en väldigt fin metafor, men du nämnde här förut att ni har begränsningar i tillväxt som är de här andra konkurrenternas, de vill ju kopiera er eller göra billigare grejer och trycka ner.
Borde man inte då ligga på en liten, du vet ni borde ligga på en liten, ett litet överflöd eller ett litet push för att motverka deras mot push så att säga.
För på dig så låter det som att vi gör det vi ska göra och vi gör det på det sättet som vi tycker att man ska göra, men borde man inte överkompensera lite?
Ja, hur menar du då?
Överkompensera vad?
Säg att ni väljer att ta, vi säger att ni har en viss Sula till exempel, en viss teknologi och så kommer en viss aktör till er i olika länder som ni inte är inne i och så säger de hej kan inte vi få köpa den Sulan av er eller licensera den Sulan?
Och då kanske ni säger nej för att ni tänker att nej men de har inte samma syn som oss.
Men det är inte bra att licensera ut den Sulan och få ett litet steg in där som bara blir en passiv inkomst för att ni ska kunna liksom göra rätt på era andra marknader så att säga.
Ja ja ja, jag fattar.
Men jag tror inte att det är någon riktig motsats.
Men vi är intresserade av att göra goda affärer och jag tänker att vi lyckas ganska bra med det.
Och sen så är det sådär, okej, men den där frågan är kopplad till, okej, om det är så att, och där har vi gjort ett vägval.
Vi vill göra, också göra affärer på rätt sätt.
Det vi tycker är rätt sätt.
Och då finns ju en så här inre begränsning av att vi vill inte exploatera människor.
Och en yttre begränsning är att vi inte vill exploatera planeten.
Och då blir ju någon slags donut kvar.
Och där kan vi skapa en massa värde.
Och vi liksom inte klarar på långa vägar i att skapa värde i den där, om vi inte vuxit i den kostymen.
Fan, det är bara lite...
Det är för många frågor här.
Det blir en del begränsningar, så blir det.
Vi gör ju livet svårare för oss.
Och jag tror, med andra sidan så får vi en del positiva associationer av det sådär.
Och varumärkesvärdet blir starkare.
Jag tror att framför allt, jag tror att utåt så varumärkesverket finns ett varumärkesvärde.
Men framför allt så blir engagemanget från personal väldigt, väldigt starkt, upplever jag.
Och det här är jätteintressant, för det här är liksom när man tittar på sådana som Patagonia, till exempel.
Så det är väldigt tydligt att de får ett varumärkesvärde.
Produkterna i sig är inte superspeciella jämfört med en massa andra 8-åriga grejer, men många väljer dem för att de var med att starta 1% för det planet och så där.
Och de är autentiska och fattar beslut utifrån sitt syfte.
Men, the purpose of purpose is purpose.
Man kan inte ha ett syfte som har ett annat syfte än syftet, för då blir det inte trovärdigt.
Man kan inte göra sånt för att man ska bygga det här varumärket som verkar syftesdrivet.
Och det förstår man inte i analyser ibland.
Man tror att det kanske är något smart man har gjort för att öka sitt marknadsvärde.
Jag tror att man kan inte göra det av den anledningen.
Så det här är en paradox.
Man kan inte göra det av den anledningen, men samtidigt ökar man sitt marknadsvärde för att man gör det.
Ja men jag köper det.
Det är exakt därför jag tar, det är därför jag inte brukar prata om den här dialogen i sådana här poddar.
För jag tycker att ganska ofta så är det såhär, det där är ett beslut som man har tagit utifrån ett genomtänkt beslut för att man tänker på sin kundgrupp typ.
Ja men det är inte så sådana beslut ska komma fram.
Så jag tycker att det är lite intressant.
När du pratar med kollegor och personal och det blir ju också på något sätt, även om det vi pratar om nu kanske handlar mycket om miljö eller liknande, så kopplas ju det lite till hur man beter sig i grupp.
Alltså att man är schysst och man pratar bonusar till personal och liknande.
Det går ju lite hand i hand.
Vart drar man gränsen där?
Hur karg får man vara, till exempel?
Vi jobbar ju också ganska mycket med, det har vi inte pratat så mycket om än, men hela, vi har jobbat väldigt mycket med inre utveckling som en del av det.
Vi har ju såhär såhär tanke vart ska en arbetsplats vara.
Vi har ju dels de här tre timmarna obligatoriska i sina situationsdäkter, friskvård i veckan när vi stänger kontoret mellan 11 och 12 måndag, onsdag och fredag.
Och alla behöver ta sig ut och göra någon typ av aktivitet, ingen sån här krav på vad det är men att man tar sig ut, gör någonting, många springer ju.
Jag brukar spela fotbollsständning ibland såhär så att man gör något kul.
Det är många som är ut och går i skogen också, plockar svamp kan man säga.
Så det är en del såhär för att bygga det här till.
Okej, hur gör man en arbetsplats i rätt ställe där man inte slits ner utan där man ökar hälsa, välbefinnande och utvecklas mot sin fulla potential.
Där har vi också jobbat en hel del med det som är intresse.
Det är ju din utveckling men den är inte bara individuell, utan vi gör den också i grupp för vi är ju så mycket de relationerna vi har.
En ganska stor anledning till det här kommer ju från att vi har jobbat först med ledarskapsutbildning, sen har vi jobbat med hur utvecklar man tid, och sen blev det här som en logisk konsekvens och hur jobbar man med det inre.
Och det blir ju en brott mot business-
och djurskölj att säga att det inre är någonting som man inte bara kan utan också bör ta ansvar för att utveckla.
För mig så kom det här ganska mycket från under pandemin, så gjorde jag en väldigt stor egen utvecklingsresa.
Det är stort sett våren under pandemin, och det drev jag också på före idag.
Då gick man från ganska förutsägbar verklighet till att varannan veckas var det som allt var uppkastat i luften och man hade ingen aning liksom.
Kommer det att finnas någon kvar, någon betyg kvar att leverera till tidsdagen.
Så jag var ju tvungen att växla från det här.
För jag pratar ju när man börjar spela en roll och leker någonting.
Och när jag liksom blev vd så byggde jag ganska förtjuset den här bilden av sig själv som vd, som den som är smartast, har de vassaste frågorna.
Och framförallt man gör en plan.
Och så har man ett hög grad av följer vi den här planen så kommer det här att hända.
Och jag blev bara tvungen att erkänna att jag har ingen aning.
Vi får försöka liksom anpassa oss och lösa det här tillsammans när saker går.
Vi kan försöka styra i den här riktningen.
Och det där var ju för mig att omfamna en sårbarhet jag inte hade visat på jobbet tidigare.
Och det var läskigt men det var ju också en paradox att det gjorde mig inte svagare utan tvärtom starkare.
För man behövde inte försöka dölja saker.
Och med det så kunde jag ju visa tacksamhet på ett helt annat sätt.
Och folk blev ju inte lat av det som jag på något sätt hade trott innan.
Utan de ville ju bidra mer.
Och också deltäckliga ädgar på jobbet.
Jag var lite så här är det för glatt.
Nu kanske vi inte jobbar ordentligt.
Och jag kunde ta med mig till även min familj och bli mindre av att man driver saker.
Och liksom låter saker känna vad är det som vill hända här och inte alltid ställa sig i vägen för det.
Och när det är bra saker som vill hända så låter man dem hända.
Och det där är väl kanske sådär, ja men hur snäll kan man vara så?
Och just, ja men, öppenhet och den typen av sårbarhet, den tror jag inte att det finns några problem att ha.
Sen så behöver man ju, ja men, dra gränser och säga nej.
Och till exempel, det är inte så att vi är väldigt tydliga med, och det handlar ju om att ta ansvar för makt också.
Vi är tydliga med att vi är ingen demokratisk institution.
Och vissa saker, om ni pratar strategi till exempel, om man ska jämföra det här med idrottstermen, så det kan ju vara så att, om jag då är coach och säger, ja men vi ska spela zonförsvar, och så är det någon som säger, nej men jag tycker att vi ska spela man-man av de här och de här anledningarna.
Ska jag säga, ja jag hör vad du säger men, och det finns många sätt att vinna, det är jag helt mervet om, men vi ska spela zon, det blir bäst för oss.
Då måste man sedan gå ut och så ska alla spela zon.
Då kan inte någon hålla på och spela man-man.
Så på det sättet så vissa saker måste man, strategisk riskriktning måste man linjera sig med.
Annars så blir det ju konsekvenser.
De som har jobbat länge i företaget, kan de se en dag vid innan covid och efter covid?
Ja men det tror jag absolut.
Det är ju de som säger att jag blivit lite skönare.
Det betyder rätt mycket skönare.
Ja.
Ja jag fattar.
Alltså skönt.
Jag har också fått den kommentaren som jag fick barn.
Du är lite mer förstående som människa nu.
Ja jag fattar vad du menar.
Jag var tur att du var först och fick barn.
Ja exakt.
En fråga till som jag skulle vilja hinna med är, du nämnde att nu för tiden så tänker du kanske lite mer 20 år framåt än 20 månader framåt.
Och du pratar om den här eken och liknande.
Men vad innebär det konkret när du ser på dig 20 år framåt?
Vad är det, vad är du på riktigt och hoppas att Iceberg här ska vara?
Jag har inte egentligen, jag gör inte den typen av målbilder framåt, brukar jag väldigt väldigt sällan göra.
Jag tror det är mer, jag är alltid mer intresserad av att ha en vardag eller rutin eller det jag gör hela tiden som funkar.
Så jag tror att det det framför allt gör är att vi fattar liksom inga kortsiktiga beslut.
Vi försöker alltid fatta beslut så att de har rätt.
Och vi har ju en riktning vi vill röra oss i.
Riktningen är ju att bidra till globalt hållbara blomstrande livsår.
Vi tar inte bort den riktningen även när vi fattar när vi fattar beslut i det dagliga.
Men har det uppstått lite problem där eller har det alltid varit logiskt?
Nej, det är ju logiskt är det väl, men det som är...
Jag tror att det finns några saker som gör det till svårt att jobba hos oss.
Och ännu är det att vi försöker navigera efter vad som skapar värde.
Och där har alla ett ansvar för att koppla det de gör sitt jobb till, att det skapar värde för teamet, att det skapar värde för det hela Iceberg.
Så det finns ju ingen som kan gå och komma till oss och bara ha en såhär, här är min lista över arbetsuppgifter och så bockar jag alla dem och så kommer man hem och så är man färdig.
Precis som samma sätt ingen har, det kan ju vara som någon gång ibland men som generell reprincip, så det är ingen som bara gör arbetsuppgifter de redan behärskar.
Alla ska alltid ha saker som de inte kan än, som man behöver lära sig och sträcka sig in i.
För där finns ju den där personliga utvecklingspotentialen.
Att det blir man behöver gå in i det där.
Utvecklingen sker ju inte i bekvämlighetszonen, det sker heller inte i panikzonen.
Men begreppet för det är så här, måttligt obehag.
Man behöver gå in i det måttliga obehaget då och då, relativt ofta för att utveckla.
Sen får man gå tillbaka och vila, men där finns liksom de där arbetsuppgifter man inte behärskar än.
Så det är ju ganska svårt och där behöver man ge tillräckligt mycket kontext och hjälpa till som ledare så att inte navigera, vad ska jag göra för att skapa värde, bli så ansträngd ändå, men inte ha någon energi kvar till att göra jobbet sen.
Fan, har du haft några kollegor några gånger som bara helvete David, jag vill bara sälja skor, kan inte jag bara få...
Jag skiter väl i de här extrauppgifterna, jag är bara bra på att sälja skor.
Ja men dom är...
Sluta nu!
Nej vi har, vi har tre saker vi säger är lika viktiga.
Det är att få jobbet gjort, och sen är det att utvecklas, och sen är det att samarbeta och bidra till kulturen.
För vår hypotes här är ju att, ja men det viktigaste företaget kan göra är att, för att bli långsiktigt framgångsriktig, att vi utvecklar våra förmåga.
För det kommer att göra att vi kommer att kunna göra bättre resultat framåt, så utvecklas vi inte, lär vi oss inte nya saker, så kommer vi ganska snabbt att stagnera och då kommer någon annan att springa om oss.
Så det är väl det vi tänker som är vår huvudsakliga konkurrensfördel, med att ha det här sättet att jobba, som är lite svårt att man tar till vara, mycket mer av den potential som finns i företaget.
Och vi gör ju den här utvecklingen också för alla.
Det är inte så att vi har någon sån här talangprogram eller så där.
För då säger man ju om man har 20 procent man säger har potential, då säger man ju till de andra 80, du har ingen potential.
Det blir ett kast ställe att jobba på.
Fan jag gillar det.
David jag tror att jag har ställt två av de frågorna jag hade tänkt ställa under den här intervjuerna.
Helt underbart.
Och det var ju också jättebra frågor, jag läste dem innan så ja det var synd.
Jag är oerhört tacksam över att vi fick låna din tid här.
Tack så jättemycket.
Tack.
En företag som heter MVP, som Million Dollar Projects.
Fan vad underbart, fan vad glad jag blir.